[Musik]
hallo meine süßen heute gibt es ein
dessert und zwar eines das nicht
gebacken werden muss also ein notebook
bisher und ich habe gedacht da durch das
ist jetzt eben so warm ist verzichte ich
auch noch zusätzlich auf sahne und das
rezept geht auch wirklich sehr schnell
und ist total anfänger geeignet ich
fange jetzt auch direkt an ich fange
jetzt mit der creme an hier habe ich
mascarpone und diesmal nämlich schmandt
ihr könntet schwand auch durch creme
fraiche ersetzen aber ich schreibe euch
sowieso alle ganz genauen mengenangaben
hier unten in die video beschreibung
jetzt verrückt dass und wir brauchen
außerdem auch keine pflicht maschine
also in diesem rezept brauchte wirklich
sehr wenig das gebe ich das da rein und
verrät uns einfach mit dem schneebesen
[Musik]
so mascarpone und schmand habe ich auch
nur kurz miteinander verrührt wichtig
ist eben dass ich zu viel und zu lange
rührt damit sich die flüssigkeit nicht
trennt jetzt gebe ich da noch die
folgenden vier zutaten dazu einmal
puderzucker für die süße sahne fest das
bindet auch noch mal so ein bisschen
dann für den geschmack vanille extrakt
und außerdem hase nicht brotaufstrichen
das berühren wir dann auch nur ganz kurz
miteinander
und die creme ist fertig wir machen auch
direkt weiter ich habe mir meinen back
rahmen und den habe ich auf einen torten
retter gestellt einfach damit ich nur
unterlage habe und jetzt beginnen wir zu
schichten ich nehme jetzt als boden die
lorca napolitaner ich habe euch locker
schon mal vorgestellt in einem video
dass verlinkt ich euch auch gerne lorca
das ist ein familienunternehmen aus
südtirol finde ich persönlich sehr cool
und support ich sehr gerne und was ich
auch super wichtig findet die benutzten
eben kein vanillin kein künstliches
vanillin sondern nur echte bombay lebt
so und da öffentlich wird einfach mal
ein paar packungen und schichte den
boden damit und dann kommt die komplette
creme darüber
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich alles glatt verstrichen
und wenn ihr euren back rahmen auf 21 x
24 cm einstellt dann passt es perfekt
mit dem napolitano und die restlichen
werde ich jetzt in quadrate schneiden
oder so wir sind klein schneiden für die
deko später ohne die leute möchten
bisschen naschen nun müssen sie auch
stärken und dann zeige ich euch die
glasur ja das stimmt deswegen teile von
tieren
[Musik]
für die schokoladenglasur jetzt ganz
einfach voll mit kuvertüre zusammen mit
butter über einem wasserbad erhitzen und
schmelzen lassen und das gibt ihr dann
über die mascarpone creme jetzt müssen
wir das ganze nur noch kühlen und je
länger er kühlt desto fester wird die
mascarpone creme ich denke mal zwei
stunden sollten ausreichend falls ihr es
ganz am vortag vorbereiten möchtet dann
könnt ihr das sehr gerne tun und lassen
es einfach über nacht im kühlschrank so
und danach lösen wir ganz einfach noch
den dax mit dem bug vom löser und
dekorieren nach herzenslust genau nach
herzenslust natürlich passen napolitano
am besten oder auch haselnüsse oder aber
frische früchte passend zur saison passt
auch immer wunderbar und uns schmeckt
das ganze sehr sehr gut weil eben was
capone und spannend und frische kombi
ist und ja ansonsten würde ich euch
jetzt ganz viel freude beim nachmachen
backen müsst er nicht schreibt mir gerne
weitere rezept wünsche hier unten in die
kommentare abonniert den kanal komplett
kostenlos damit ihr nichts mehr verpasst
und dann sehen wir uns auch beim
nächsten rezept schiffes eure klicken
[Musik]